روسيا تقصف بكثافه مناطق خارج خط المواجهه
الرئيسيه شرقي اوكرانيا
وسط جدلا ليبيا وغياب مصري اجتماع لوزراء
الخارجيه العرب في طرابلس
بعد تفتيش منزل بيدن العثور على 36 سريه
اضافيه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى هذه النشره وقبل تفاصيلها نتابع
مجريات افتتاح السوق مع نادين
صباح الخير اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد
مشاهدينا لنلقادر على افتتاح سوق الاسهم
السعوديه لليوم مؤشر السوق كان بدا الجلسه
على بعض الارتفاع باربعه عشر النقطه
المئويه المستويات 10,000
واثنتين و 20 نقطه بالوقت الحاضر على
الاسهم لنرى من اين الارتفاع
اليوم بنصف نقطه مئويه واقوى باور على
ارتفاع بسته اعشار النقطه المئويه هناك
شركه مشتركه
وايضا شركات اخرى
25% هذه شركه تسعى لتملك اصول طعنه بقطاع
الغاز من ارامكو اليوم تم الاستحواذ على
الدفعه الثانيه من الاصول تم الانتهاء
منها من شركات ارامكو اجمالي هذه الاصول
تكلفتها 12 مليار دولار اقوى باور واقراكم
على ارتفاع اليوم ادريس على ارتفاع ثلاثه
ارباع نقطه المئويه مجلس الاداره اوصى
بتوزيعات نقديه عن العام الماضي 2022
بقيمه 2 ريال لكل سهم بس الحقيقه بعد مش
واضحه لان هي بتاريخ الجمعيه العموميه
التي سيتم تحديد اديها لاحقا اماك اليوم
على ارتفاع ايضا حصلت على رخصه للتنقيب عن
الذهب من وزاره الصناعه والثروه المعدنيه
اكيد ستقوم بالاستكشافات اللازمه ومن بعد
تعلن اذا كان في اثر مالي انها كانت نتيجه
الدراسات المراعي على ثبات السهم ملفت
مطلع جلسه اليوم كان عندها ارتفاع
بالارباح الصافيه بالارادات ولكن على صعيد
الارباح الثانويه اتت اقل من المتوقع رغم
انه الارادات الثانويه اعلى من المتوقع
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني كان في ارتفاع بتكلفه
اثر سلبا على ربح الصافيه على رغم انها
باعت اكثر وبالتالي على مدار السنه
المراعي باعت 18% اعلى من العام الاسبق
18.7 مليار ريال مبيعاتها اعلى من متوسط
توقعات المحللين انما الارباح الصافيه
ارتفعت ب 12.5% الى مليار و760 مليون ريال
اقل من متوسط توقعات البالغ مليار و840
مليون ريال على سعيد ربع الرابع عند
ارتفاع بالارباح 24% عن نفس الفتره من
العام الماضي تتحدث عن ارتفاع بمبيعات
قطعيه الدواجن والمخبوزات فانا المراعي
على ثبات خلينا نشوف بعض القياديه بقطاع
المواد الاساسيه سابق على ميل للارتفاع ب
20 من النقطه المئويه معادن على ارتفاع
بنصف نقطه مئويه لوبراف ايضا فاذن اداء
جيد اليوم على قطاع المواد الاساسيه ما
عدا سابق للمغذيات الزراعيه لانه
بالفورتيلايزر شوي مختلف عن الباقي على
تراجع السهم بقطاع المصاريف كل المصارف
اللي عم شوفها صباح اليوم على ارتفاع
لاسيه مع الفرنسي راجحي ورياض الاسهم
الكبرى بقطع الاتصالات عن الاتحاد
الاتصالات موبايلي على بعض التراجع زين
على ثبات عذيب على ميل للارتفاع ذكر انه
على مدار الاسبوع الماضي مرتفع بشكل جيد
ثلاثه من المكاسر اكثر الارتفاع عن صباح
اليوم صدر سعودي الالماني الصحيه تهامه
الورق والمملكه القابضه الاكثر تراجعا ليس
ليست بتراجعات الحظ الحاده لاحظوا اقل من
واحد بالمئه سنكتفي بهذا القدر من الاخبار
للان انا عضو القاكم ضمن برنامج نبض السوق
بعد قليل العوده اليك فاطمه الانبار
صباح الخير قال مسؤولون من منطقتين برجا
وسومي الاوكرانيتين ان روسيا كثافه قصفها
لمناطقه واقعه شرق اوكرانيا خارجه خط
المواجهه الرئيسي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
افادت بان قواتها تحتل مواقع مميزه بشكل
اكبر على طول خطي لجبهه زابوريجيا
وبالتالي تستهدف الهجمات الروسيه زياده
العب على دفاعات اوكرانيا ومنعكييف من
استعاده الاراضي وفقا مسؤولينا ومحللين
وقال حاكموا منطقه
166 مره بينما اوضح حاكم منطقه سوميرو
القوات الروسيه 115 هجوما في المنطقه
ورصد فريق العربيه الوضع على خطوط
المواجهه بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
في امريكا التي تشهد معارك ساخنه
مع المقاتلين الى مدينه
الملتهبه بالمعاركي شمال غربيه
المقاتلين لارض المعركه عبر حاملات الجنود
المدينه الذي سيطر عليه الجيش الروسي
الهدفه والوصول الى فنادق خط المواجهه
الاول
هذه اثار المعارك الضاريه والساخنه التي
شهدتها هذه المدينه مدينه مارك خلال
الاشهر الماضيه حيث سيطر الجيش الروسي على
جزء كبير من هذه المدينه الحديث عن ثلثي
المدينه والمتبقي الثلث الاخير وهي
الابنيه الشاهقه سرنا كاسراب النمل حذرين
من الالغام بمحاذاه الجدران خشيه القناصه
في الثلث الاخير من المدينه يشتبك
المقاتلون بالبنادق وضعنا كاميرا على خوذه
مقاتل خلال عمليات الاقتحام التي تهدف
لاكمال السيطره على المدينه
يا الله
بعيد
[موسيقى]
على ضوء شمعه والدبابات تقصف موقعنا عبر
المسيرات
مر الدقائق الليل كالسنين بانتظار بزوق
الفجر على اثير الرشاقات الرصاص والصواريخ
ينفذ الجيش الروسي عمليات اقتحام في مدينه
ماركا الكائنه شمال الغرب مقاطعه دانيت
اليوم بالذات القوات الخاصه الروسيه تنفذ
عمليه اقتحام على هذه الابنيه ذات الخمسه
الطوابق نسمع اصوات الاشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه وايضا اصوات القصب
المدفعي والقصف بالدبابات لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاخضر
وتعتزموا مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه القتاليه
رساله جثامنه جنود اوكرانيين قتلوا خلال
المعارك في بلده سوليدار وذلك الى مناطق
تسيطر عليها اوكرانيا في اربع او خمس
قوافل تضم اجمال النحو 20 شاحنه وفق
رويترز ولم تشر المجموعه الى عدد الجسميم
التي سيتم اعادتها الى السلطات الاوكرانيه
لكنها ذكرت ان القوات الاوكرانيه بنيت
بخسائر فادحه في سوليدار وعلى صعيد اخر
تساءل مؤسس مجموعه
عن الجريمه التي اتهمت بها شركته التي ادت
الى قرار تصنيفها من قبل الولايات المتحده
بمنظمه اجراميه دوليه على ان يتم الاسبوع
المقبل الاعلان عن عقوبات الاضافيه ضدها
ومع تزايد الضغوط الاوكرانيه والغربيه على
المانيا لتسليم دبابات ليوبارد الى كييف
اعلن وزير الدفاع الالماني فور سبيستوريوس
انه سيزور كيف قريبا لبحر مساله تسليم تلك
الدبابات واكد ان بلاده مستعده لارسالها
بالفعل مشيرا الى انه على حوار وثيق مع
الحلفاء في النيتو ومع الولايات المتحده
على وجه الخصوص من اجل التوصل الى اتخاذ
قرار بشان عمليه التسليم
[موسيقى]
وزاره دفاع النيدو اجتمعوا في المانيا
وفشلوا بارسال دبابات ثقيله الى اوكرانيا
اصابع اليوم توجهت صوب المانيا التي قيل
انها رفضت ارسال دباباتها
الا اذا قامت امريكا بذلك اولا
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا رات ان ذلك تردد قاتل
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه على تويتر التردد في
هذه المرحله يقتل المزيد من مواطنين
الى التفكير بشكل اسرع
[موسيقى]
من جهه اخرى اعرب عن اسفيه لموقف المانيا
الحذر في هذا الشان
البنتاجون انتقادات لاذعه لالمانيا
[موسيقى]
محبطون من موقف المانيا ويبدو انها لا
تعرف الفرق بين دباباتنا ودباباتها
والسيناتور الامريكيه الجمهوريه
واشنطن معا مباشره بعد زيارته لكيف
اجره روسيا تدريبات على نظام دفاعا الجوي
في سماء العاصمه موسكو في خطوه تعد الاولى
منذ بدايه الحرب في فبراير الماضي ضد
اوكرانيا فيما افاد التقارير صحفيه ان
الانظمه الدفاعيه تعكس رغبه روسيا في
اعاده تامين نفسها
روسيا تنفذ تدريبات تحاكي صد هجوم مفترض
على العاصمه موسكو قد يكونوا بالصواريخ او
بغارات تنفذها طائرات او مسيرات غربيه وان
كان بيان الدفاع الروسيه بررها بانها
للتصدي لهجوم مجموعه تخريبيه لعدو وهمي
تكمن اهميه التدريبات في انها تظهر مخاوف
روسيا من تعرض عاصمتها لهجمه مع وصول
اسلحه غربيه متقدمه لاوكرانيا خاصه بعد
تنفيذ هجمات على مناطق حدوديه روسيه مثل
بالجورد وتعرض قواعد عسكريه لهجمات
بمسيرات في عمق الروسي كما حدث في سيرته
وريزان فضلا عن مناطق ذمتها روسيا
كالقرمرم او لنيتها القيامه بعمليه عسكريه
كبيره تخشى ردا غربيا عليها حيث تتوقع
دوائر المخابرات الغربيه قيام روسيا
بعمليه واسعه في اوكرانيا واحتمال دخول
بلاروسيا معها
نشر انظمه دفاع جوي على اسطح ابنيه في
موسكو يراه البعض تناقضا مع التصريحات
الروسيه التي تؤكد ان مسار العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا يسير على ما يرام
وافق قطط وزاره الدفاع اما عن الاسباب
فيرجع مراقبون الامر للتخوف من امتلاك
اوكرانيا مسيرات يصل مداها الى الف كيلو
متر ما يعني وصولها الى العاصمه الروسيه
فيما يرى البعض ان ذلك جزء من الدعايه
الروسيه وذلك عبر اظهار التهديد قد تتعرض
له موسكو لسكان العاصمه وتصوير اوكرانيا
على انها عدو لروسيا ما يزيد التعيييد
الشعبي لما تسميها روسيا عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى زياده
نسبه التطوع في القوات الروسيه هو ذلك هو
حديث عن تعبئه جديده قد تكون غير معلنه
قال بانه لديه امكانيه للوصول نحو الف
كيلومتر عبر المسيرات التي طورها ولذلك
يمكن ان تصل الى مدينه موسكو لكن كما قلت
ربما تكون روسيا تحضر الراي العام الروسي
من اجل معركه طويله وادعوا دفاعات جويه
على اسطح المنازل في موسكو مشهد قد يكون
الاول منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهو
المشهد الذي يستحضر تلك الاجواء ويهدد
بحرب كبيره الاكثر من ذلك تدريبات روسيا
كانت تهدف لحمايه منشات عسكريه بدواحي
موسكو بنشر منظومه اس 300 بهدف التصدي
لهجوم بالطائرات والصواريخ البالستيه وهي
التي تملكها حصرا دول النيترو
موسكو سبق وان تعرضت لهجوم في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وتمكن الاتحاد السوفيتي
من وقف تقدم دبابات هتلر نحو المدينه
حينها فهل نحن امام تصعيد جديد في الحرب
باوكرانيا قد يصل مداه الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو
مه الاستقرار فتحي باشا يجتمع وزراء
وخارجيه الدول العربيه في العاصمه الليبيه
طرابلس بدعوه من رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميدبا وسجره امنيه
عقد الاجتماع مخالفه لاجراءات قوانين
الجامعه العربيه ودعت وزاره الخارجيه في
حكومه باشا الى الانتظار لاخذ راي
القانوني في شكله النهائي والاخذ
بالاعتبار شرعيه الحكومه الليبيه
ومن المفترض ان تقدم توصيات هذا الاجتماع
الى الجامعه العربيه بشكل رسمي الاعتمادها
بحسب مراسل العربيه في ليبيا والذي اضاف
ان الوفود ستبدا بالوصول الى مطار
معتاتيجا ويسبق الاجتماعي استمفارا امني
حيث اعلنت مديريه امن طرابلس اغلاق العديد
من الطرق الرئيسيه لتسهيل مرور الوفود
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها
اجلاؤه اكثر من 400 سائح من معلم سياحي
وسط اضطرابات في برو
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب
[موسيقى]
في قوه الدول
وحسن الزراعه
ولعل قاده العالم
[موسيقى]
فقد يعرفون اسرارا لا نعرفها
فمن يتحكم بموازين القوى وكيف تدار
الصفقات
الاكثر اهميه وتعقيدا وتنافسا في العالم
عسكريتاريا
السبت العاشره والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاوقات على شاشه العربيه
اجتماعها الاسبوعيه
من حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الاستماع
هذه المظاهره ستكون فقط البدايه لسلسله
مظاهرات حسب تعبير احدى المنظمات المسؤوله
عن تنظيمها في ظل تخوف الحكومه من تحول
المظاهرات الى انقسامات داخليه اكبر
واصيان مدنييا محتمل لا نقول غاصي من تل
ابيب العربيه
نقلت وسائل الاعلام من سوريا المحليه
انباء عن مقتل 10 اشخاص بانهيار مبنا بحي
الشيخ الشيخ مقصود في حلب وعن فقدان 30
شخصا على الاقل تحت انقاض المبنى المنهار
واوضحت وسائل الاعلام السوريه ان المبنى
المنهار بالشيخ مقصود في حلب
من عفرين
قال المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لمحاربه داعش
السفير جيمري في مقابله مع العربيه
في سوريا والعراق
[موسيقى]
تقرير جديد يلقي الضوء على انتهاكات
مليشيات الحوثي ضد المهاجرين الافارقه
وكيف يقومون باجبارهم على قتال الشعب
اليمني تحت التهديد السلوك الحوثي وسطوه
المليشيات حولت حياه اللاجئين القادمين من
افريقيا الى جحيم
من منطقه القرن الافريقي من اثيوبيا
والصومال قطعوا مضيق باب المندب الى اليمن
وكلهم امل في ان يجد الامان لكنهم لم
يواجهوا غير القسوه والغدر
كل شيء مغلق على المنظمه مغلقه عادي كاسات
حرب يعني زي حرب يعني ما يشتوش عاد جينا
هنا
من قبل ميليشيات الحوثي في الحرب لقتل
اليمنيين واذا رفضوا تلقوا اشد
العقوباتنا من زمان
[موسيقى]
تفوقوا ايه تصور بل هي اقرب لممارسات
النازي
كبير بحق الافارقه والمهاجرين سواء كان
المهاجرين الشرعيه او غير الشرعيه همم
بالتالي هي قامت كان في هناك محرقه عملتها
مليشيات الحوثي هذه المحرقه عنها مقتل
المئات وحريق همم يعني عدد كبير من هؤلاء
طارق
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده سجلت وصول اكثر من 73 الف مهاجرين
افريقي الى اليمن خلال العام الماضي ياتون
الى اليمن ليتمكنوا من تقديم طلبات الهجره
او اللجوء من خلال السفارات الاجنبيه
والمنظمات الانسانيه
لكنهم لا يجدون الاضطهاد والعنف والتجنيد
القصري من قبل ميليشيات الحوثي العربيه
قال المحامي الشخصي للرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن باور قال انا مو حقيقي وزاره العدل
عثروا على سته وثائق سريه اضافيه خلال
عمليه تفتيش في منزلي
في بيان رسمي انه خلال عمليه البحث التي
استغرقت قرابه اثنتي عشره ساعه استحوذت
وزاره العدل على المواد التي اعتبرتها ضمن
نطاق تحقيقها بما في ذلك 6 وثائق سريه
تعود للفتره التي كان يشغل فيها بيض منصبه
نائب الرئيس
نشرت صحيفه نيويورك تايم تقريرا كشفت فيه
ان رئيس موظفي البيت الابيض ارون كلاين قد
يتنحى قريبا وتزامنا مع التحقيق بوثائق
بيض السريه الصحيفه وصفت الاستقاله
المرتقبه بانها اهم تغير في اداره الرئيس
الامريكي منذ ان تولى بيض منصبه قبل عامين
الابيض السريه
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز كشفت ان مغادره
رونكلين قد تاتي بعد خطاب بيض المقرر في
السابع من فبراير
الصحيفه وصفت الاستقاله المرتقبه بانها
اهم تغيير في اداره بيض منذ توليه الرئاسه
قبل عامين
بارو مسؤولي اداره بيضا قالوا ان البحث
جار عن بديل ومن المحتمل ان يستمر كلين
لفتره الانتقاليه
تاتي المغادره ايضا في وقت يواجه البيت
الابيض مجموعه واسعه من التهديدات
السياسيه والقانونيه
قالت وزاره السياحه في فروق ان فرقه
الانقاذ اجلت اكثر من 400 سائح تقطعت بهم
السبل في قلعه الانك الشهيره في ماتشو
بيتشو وتم نقلهم الى كاسكو حيث عطلت
الاحتجاجات في جميع انحاء البلاد خدمات
النقل هذا وتشهد العاصمه لمحتجاجات واسعه
يطغى عليها العنف ضد حكومه
واعتقاله بعد محاولته حل الكونجرس
اعلنا قصر بيكنجهام انه سيتم الاحتفال
بتتويج ملك بريطانيا تشارلز الثالث لمده
ثلاثه ايام بدا من السادس من مايو المقبل
وبمركبه بمواكب تقليديه وحفل الموسيقي في
قلعه وينستير ويعد هذا التتويج الحدث
الرئيسي للعائله المالكه البريطانيه خلال
عام 2023 وسيكون اليوم الثامن من مايو
اجازه مصرفيه للبريطانيين احتفالا بهذه
المناسبه
وسيتمكنون من مشاهده الاحتفالات بالاضافه
الى مشاهده اضاءه المباني الشهيره باشعه
الليزر وعروض بطائرات مسيره
نهايه النشره الى العناوين
روسيا تقصف بكثافه مناطق الخارج خط
المواجهه الرئيسي شرق اوكرانيا
وغياب المصري اجتماع للوزراء الخارجيه
العرب في طرابلس
وبعد تفتيش منزل بيض من العثور على 6
وثائق سريه
في امان الله